(staccato synth music)
- Welcome to A Conversation with History.
I'm Harry Kreisler of the Institute
of International Studies.
Our distinguished guest
today is Daniel Kahneman,
who is the Eugene Higgins
Professor of Psychology
at Princeton University
and professor of psychology
in public affairs at the
Woodrow Wilson School
of Public and International Affairs.
In 2002 he received the
Nobel Prize in Economics
for his work with Amos
Tversky on human judgment
and decision making.
A former professor of
psychology at Berkeley,
he is the Hitchcock
Professor in the spring 2007.
Professor Kahneman,
welcome back to Berkeley.
- Thank you.
- Where were you born and raised?
- I was born in Tel Aviv,
which was then Palestine,
and I was raised in
France until the age of 12
when we went back to Palestine.
- And looking back, how
do you think your parents
shaped your thinking about the world?
- Well, you know, I grew up
in a Jewish environment, and
I think my mother had
more to do with shaping
my view of the world in
some ways than my father.
My father was a researcher but my mother
certainly influenced my development.
She was very interested
in people, and I lived
in a world that consisted
of people and words, really.
I was never very interested
in nature or in animals,
but people and words I
was really fascinated by
from an early age.
- And you were in Europe,
in France, during the war.
I would imagine that experience really had
an impact on your thinking, or did it?
Well, you know, undoubtedly it shaped me.
I don't know what I would have been
without that experience, but certainly
I went through a lot of experiences
that more fortunate children don't have,
and I was luckier than
most of the children
of my generation in
that place in the world.
- You describe in your
official autobiography,
The Nobel Laureate, an incident
where you were coming home once.
Would you mind retelling that story?
'Cause it's quite fascinating.
- Well, must have been
the fall of '41, I think,
where there was a curfew for Jews.
We were all supposed to
be wearing a yellow star.
And there was a curfew,
which I think was 6 p.m.
And I was in first grade,
was first or second grade.
And I'd gone to play with a
friend, and I was going home,
and I missed the curfew; I was late.
And so I turned my sweater
inside out and walked home
and as I was coming close,
I remember the street
was deserted, and there
was this German soldier
walking towards me and he
was wearing the black uniform
and I knew that that was not good.
That was the uniform
of the SS, and we were
walking towards each other,
as we were coming close
he sort of beckoned me,
and of course I went there
and he picked me up and hugged me.
And I remember being terrified, you know,
that he would see the star
of David inside my sweater,
and then he put me down
and took out his wallet
and showed me a picture of a
boy, and gave me some money.
And yeah, that's a
formative memory in a way
because of what it meant about
the complexity of things.
I mean, I remember being
very fascinated at the time
by this and by stories
of Hitler liking flowers
and kissing babies, and
the complexity of evil was
much on my mind at a seven-
or eight-year-old, I think.
- And I guess the, in
retrospect, the expectation
about what somebody like that would do
if he were rational and
following the orders
of his organization.
- No, it was ...
It was more the complexity of the moment
and the basic humanity of
the fellow who was clearly
quite capable of being
inhumane at other times,
and I think I already knew this,
but was a father and a
lonely father and with a boy
and I reminded him of the boy,
and I knew that immediately.
- After the war, you and your
mother emigrated to Israel.
- Indeed.
- Yes, and any memories
from that experience
of having that chance to
go to Israel and be there
during that very formative
period in Israel?
- Well that was, for me, it was of course
an enormous change because I was lucky.
I was held up a year.
I had been quite Jewish
and feeble in athletics,
and a bit precocious
intellectually and so on,
and in Israel everything was different.
I had basically a normal
adolescence, and I was
very grateful for that.
The period, of course, was
a very exciting period.
We went there in '46;
actually I think we arrived
the day that the famous bombing
of the King David Hotel,
which was an important
event in that story.
Then in '48 there was the war and in '51
I started my studies, and in '54 I myself
went into the army, so it was
all quite compressed in time.
- And you were educated
at Hebrew University?
- Yes, indeed.
- Right, and what was your major?
- Psychology and my minor was mathematics.
- And then you went into
the army and really became
a researcher there; talk
a little about that.
- Well, yeah, first
actually, I spent a year,
which probably in many ways
was at least as important.
I spent a year as a platoon commander.
Those things change you.
And then I was a psychologist.
And it was a period where there was
no psychology department.
The professor of
psychology had been killed
in the 1948 war and there was nothing.
And the head of the research unit
in the psychological
research unit was a chemist.
It was completely self-taught.
But the place was full of brilliant people
and there was a lot of
very good work being done.
And I was, as it were, the
best-trained psychologist.
I had a BA, which I'd proudly acquired in,
I think, two years, and I was
the best-trained psychologist
there and I did a number
of things that had
a big influence on my
development later, so
one of the things I did do
that I'm still quite proud of
actually is I set up
an interviewing system
for the Israeli army to interview
recruits for combat units, and that,
it turns out, I learned
in 2002, that interview
is still in place 50 years later.
So they have barely changed it, in fact.
So I had many experiences
that were formative
in terms of my subsequent
research on judgment.
- Let's talk about that interview.
The problem before you
was to match the skillset
with the requirements of the job.
Talk a little about that
and your thought processes.
Here you are, a young
person with only a BA
and yet you're putting in place a formula
that works.
- Well, it turns out, and
that's a bit of history
of my field in psychology that in 1954
Paul Meehl, a very famous psychologist
who died just a few years ago,
published a very important book in which
he showed that clinicians
are much less good
at what they're doing
than they think they are
and that their ability to
predict, forecast events
and psychological behavior in the future
is really quite limited.
And I must have read that book because
what I did to set up the
interview system was ...
I have no memory of reading the book
but I must have read it, 'cause what I did
was completely compatible
with what he advised.
And I created, I don't think I could do it
much better today.
I set up an interview
where people are asked ...
That didn't leave a lot of
room for clinical intuition
on part of the interviewer.
The interviewer went through
a script and found out
what the person had done
as a civilian basically.
And it turns out that when
you use that information
to produce ratings on various traits,
and you get ratings that are
predictive and are useful
on whether somebody is responsible,
appreciates manliness or
things like that, is sociable.
And in addition it turned
out and that was important
to me years later, it
turned out that when people
had acquired that information, then their
clinical judgment was in fact good.
Whereas if they were trying
to form a clinical impression,
they couldn't do it.
Now these observations
that I made at that time
became really quite
essential to my research
about 15 years later,
and they were central
to the work that ultimately led
to the Nobel Prize and so on.
So I'd started quite early
and by accident, of course.
- I'm interested in exploring with you
the skills that make for a psychologist,
in other words, this interface between
skillset and the requirements
of the discipline.
Talk a little about that
because I think students
often want to know,
well, what does it take
to do that?
I wanna do that.
- I think you must enjoy observing things
and that must be true
for also people who do
zoology or biology must
enjoy observing other things.
I like observing people, and
probably for a psychologist
it also helps a lot to
examine yourself, so I think
many of the best ideas that I've had
have come from examining events in my life
and examining how I respond
to events in my life.
So that's been a source of ideas,
inspiration is too big
a word, but certainly
a source of ideas.
Then what you learn in
the course of a career is
you learn not to ask
questions that are so vague
that there are no answers to them.
So you look for questions
that can be answered.
But you look for questions
that have a twist to them,
that are somehow interesting.
And I've been lucky;
I've had a few of those.
I think of research as a
conversation, and it really
is very much like a conversation.
Nobody, no single person dominates it,
but what does happen is when
you interject something,
when you contribute
something to a conversation,
you want to be understood,
you want to be heard,
you would like people to pay attention,
you would like it to have some influence
on the way the conversation goes.
You don't control it, but thinking
in conversational terms
and trying to say something
that is interesting as a criterion,
not merely publishable
but actually interesting.
That's been part of what moved me.
- As I listen to you talk I
have this sense of kind of
there is an element of humanity
in your research design.
In other words, I think
the Jewish expression
(speaking foreign language)
that part of what you've done in your work
is to find simple questions that then
really open up the
conversation; is that fair?
- I think it's fair.
I think, though, that I
was drawn to a particular
kind of research, but
actually I was inspired
by research that I read
as a very young professor.
I read work by somebody
who was a very famous
psychologist, Walter Mischel,
and I read his thesis,
I think it must have been
1964, and in his thesis,
he had asked children a single question.
I think he had two questions, but one was,
there is that fairy or
magician who can make of you
whatever you want to be;
what do you want to be?
And then if they said a
profession or some trait
that has to do with achievement,
it was scored one, otherwise zero.
He would give them two lollipops,
a large one and a small
one, and he would say,
you can have this one
now or that one tomorrow.
And now it turned out that
the answers of children
to those two questions
predicted everything in sight.
And I was enormously impressed by that.
And I called that the
psychology of single questions.
And it turned out to be an ideal for me
of doing research about single questions,
of having single examples,
and a few years later
I was fortunate enough to be able to do
the psychology of single questions,
and I have largely kept to that,
kept to very simple points,
making very simple points.
- An important theme in your
work is your collaboration
with Amos Tversky, and
you've talked quite a bit
about that in your
autobiography for the Nobel.
It was very fascinating
and I'd like to talk
a little about that
because it was a friendship
in which the conversation had great depth
between the two of you and
then really impacted the field.
Talk a little about the
elements of that relationship.
- I think we're both very lucky in a way
but I certainly consider
myself extraordinarily lucky.
We were close enough so
we understood each other
very well, and we also
had complementary skills,
so I'm more intuitive than he was.
He was really renowned for his clarity
and just incredible
clarity and the ability
to see the big picture, and I'm more
of an intellectual fumbler,
but I dig fairly deep, and I also have
wild flights of fancy.
And the combination of those two,
of his characteristics and mine,
and the fact that we
just got along very well
and had enormous respect for each other,
and that we enjoyed each other's company.
I think we knew it; we had
jointly we sort of had a mind
that was better than our separate minds.
And our joint mind was very, very good.
I'm not embarrassed to say that.
It was much better than mine.
So we did very good
work that way, and there
was something in the dynamic
that is especially interesting,
I think, to me, which is that
when you think on your own
as a scientist, as a
researcher, it sometimes
takes years before you
understand what you're saying,
so you first say something, you write it,
it can be published, and only years later,
you say, oh, I really said that.
It was there, it was in my mind.
Now when there are two of you conversing
that process is short-circuited.
Really, it's quite
dramatic, so I would say
vague things, and Amos would hear them,
and he would see what I
meant much more clearly
than I had when I said it.
And I think that was
really part of the secret
of our success, was that
together, through that process
of understanding each other
better than the speaker
had understood himself, we
could make a lot of progress.
We also had infinite patience,
and we enjoyed spending
six hours a day together.
- And I think at one
point you say that you
would have a thought and he
could finish it, basically?
- Well, when you spend six
hours a day with someone
for a number of years, we
knew each other's jokes
and of course we could
finish each other's thoughts,
but we kept surprising each other.
So we became very efficient, I think.
- You've used the term a conversation.
This is a subset of that.
Now, before we talk about the research
that you got the prize
for, there's an intriguing
element in your story, which
is you're a psychologist,
and you won the prize for economics,
and I guess what's of interest is,
what are your thoughts about the fact
that you were working in one discipline
and were recognized, but then disciplines
always have boundaries that
wanna limit the conversation,
but then the power of what you were saying
not only affected psychology
but also economics.
That was kind of unique in a way.
Tell us all about that.
- The first place, the element of luck
was considerable in that development.
It really didn't have to be that way.
And there was luck at several stages.
There was something that
Amos and I did together
which had something to
do with the psychology
of single questions,
which caused many people
to pay attention to our work.
And that was that we would
publish our questions
that basically explored flaws in humans'
intuitive thinking.
But our questions were very simple
and each one made a
point, and they were part
of the articles we published.
And that turned out to be quite important
to what happened to us
because the readers,
would read this and
then, the errors were not
the errors of somebody else,
you know, some subjects.
They knew, they could
recognize in themselves
that, oh yes, this is
the way my mind works.
This was almost part of our rhetoric,
not of the substance, but the
rhetoric was very effective,
so we had some economists paying attention
to our work early on.
Then when we worked on
the decision making,
which was the second thing we did together
we published the theory
paper in Econometric,
which is the prestigious
theory journal in economics.
Now we were not intending to
influence economics at all.
It was just the best journal
for the kind of articles.
Now if we had published
exactly the same article
in Psychological Review,
I would not have got
the Nobel Prize, so that
was a trivial detail.
If we'd had a hostile
referee in Econometric
we would have gone to Psych Review.
But the big event that caused the prize
is that some economists were interested,
particularly someone who
is now my closest friend,
Richard Thaler, who is an economist.
He became interested in our work.
And he is the one who
both taught me personally
economics and brought
these ideas into economics,
where they are behavioral finance.
So it's because of the work of economists
that I got the prize.
I didn't get the prize for
work that Amos and I did
just because it was very good work.
We got the prize, or I got the prize,
because he couldn't share in it,
because it had had impact on economics,
but the impact was because
people in economics
saw it was relevant,
and they were a minority
of people and they did brilliant work.
- Does this tell us
anything about new ideas
in disciplines, a general proposition
that innovation maybe
sometimes has to come
from outside?
- What I learned, and
that was something I knew.
Remember, we were approached
Amos Tversky and I
were approached by the person who is now
the president of the
Russell Sage Foundation,
Eric Warner, very early in the 1980s,
almost 25 years ago, and he asked us
what could be done, exactly 25 years ago,
he asked us what could be done to bring
psychology and economics together.
And I remember something I told him then.
I said this was not a
project on which we could
spend a lot of money, honestly.
And I told him that there
was absolutely no point
encouraging psychologists
to influence economics.
But that if there were
economists who were interested,
we should support them.
And indeed two years
later, Richard Thaler,
whose name I mentioned, came to spend
a year with me in Vancouver,
and we had a glorious year,
and we published a number
of articles together,
some of them quite important, actually.
And that was the beginning
of behavioral economics.
- Looking back, what comments
would you like to make
about creativity, if any?
In other words, from what
we've just talked about,
is there some point to be made that would
help us understand?
We've talked about collaboration,
we've talked about research design,
and then this funny set of information
or thinking passing from
one discipline to another?
- People have very
different tastes, you know.
Intellectually, they have different tastes
and there are different
skillsets and so on.
I know where my ideas
come from and pretty much
what characterizes them.
They're very simple.
And I tend to see simple things,
and sometimes I see some simple thing
that other people haven't seen before
but I don't see very complicated things.
And other people are better
at seeing complicated things.
So there are different
kinds of creativity,
and together with Tversky, we had a range
of possibilities because he was creative
in different ways than I was.
- Let's talk a little
now about your research.
And I know that that prize
is built on a whole body
of research, but I
think it would be useful
for our understanding, our audience
to understand, the very simple ideas,
if I can use your words,
that had such power
and such impact.
In your lecture you said,
"The mind is a system
"of jumps to conclusions,"
and you're looking
at one piece of that.
- Well yes, what we studied
was intuitive thinking
in the domain of judgment
under uncertainty.
This is how we started.
That is, how do people
assess the probabilities
of events and how do they
forecast the future intuitively?
And our idea was that
people use heuristics,
which are basically shortcuts,
and in my lecture, it's a
phrase I coined this week,
but I'm going to use it.
I did speak of the mind as a machine
for jumping to conclusions.
And we figured out some of
the ways that this is done.
I think the most important
one that we studied
in the first years of
our work was something
that I now call substitution,
that is, you're asked
a difficult question.
You cannot answer it, but
another answer comes to mind.
And it's an answer to a related question
which is simpler, and
without being aware of it,
you substitute the answer
for the simple question
in place of the answer
to the complicated one.
And this is how laypeople and non-experts
come up with intuitions
about very complicated
problems that baffle experts.
Some of these intuitions are good;
others are not so good,
but that's the machinery.
So that was the first part
of our work on judgment
was basically developing that idea
and fleshing it out.
- And as your thinking about these issues
has developed over time,
you're really focusing
on perception, intuition,
and cognition, right?
Well, perception, emotion, and cognition.
- The period when we were
working was the heyday
of what is called the cognitive
revolution, so at the time
psychologists were all
engaged in exploring
the mysteries of cognition,
and we were no exception.
And one novel aspect of
what we were doing was that
we imported the notion of
illusion from deception
into cognition, and so
we showed that people
make errors of intuitive
thinking that have
many of the characteristics of illusions.
That was because I was teaching
perception at the time.
This was what filled my
mind, and so the analogy
of visual perception
and how it helps inform
how we think about intuition,
that's been very important
to my thinking all the way through.
And I have explored
this idea in particular
over the last five or six years.
- Now talk a little about what you call
System One intuition.
In other words, people realize they do
the sorts of things you're describing,
but it's your description, the description
that has developed is
really an important balance
when one just focuses on
what you call System Two,
which is rationality.
- This is something
that has become explicit
in my mind only recently.
One of the things you learn is that
some ideas are taken for granted.
So for example, when we
worked we took rationality,
that people are able to
compute correct answers
to problems, that did not need explaining.
So we were not looking at that.
We were looking at mistakes.
But when the field accepted
the notion of mistakes,
then it became a
challenge that people were
sometimes able to figure things out
and to do it correctly,
and the resolution of that,
which I think is becoming widespread,
it's not original to me.
This is just generally
accepted in psychology
is that there are those two
families of mental processes;
I call them, along with others,
it's not my term either,
System One and System Two,
one of which is the
intuitive, rapid, associative,
uncontrolled, automatic kind of thing,
and the other one is rule governed,
that's the way that you
fill your income tax form,
or compute 17ths then 24, or read a map.
And so we're able to think in this way,
but most of the time
we run on the software
of System One, that is, automatically
and with little thought, and by and large,
with remarkable success and accuracy.
- In an interview somewhere
which I read with you,
you said with fear,
probability does not matter
as much; the more emotional event,
the less sensible people are.
- Well, this is a development
of the last 10 or 15 years,
so the cognitive revolution
is now over, and what is
happening in the field is
that emotion is now being ...
So the views of decision
making have changed,
and in a way, they're going
back to what was common
60, 70, 80 years ago, that is, to the idea
that there are very important conflicts
between reason and passion.
Nobody was thinking along
those lines 20 years ago
but many people are thinking
along those lines today,
and so the idea that one of the operations
of System One that is
one of the attributes
that are constantly being
evaluated by System One,
is the emotional significance of events.
So we're continuously
evaluating whether things
are good or bad, or safe,
or threatening and so on.
And our emotional responses guide us,
and our emotional
responses guide the ideas
that come to our minds.
- Well, in one thing that I read possibly
in the autobiography,
the issue arose that,
very important to your work, is the way
one defines a problem, and I guess
that is the problem you're researching,
so that in the area of
risk and loss, for example,
your thinking as I understand it, sort of
opened up our understanding of how
people perceive risk and loss in economic
decision making, because previously
the focus had been just
on wealth, that is,
the entire fortune that was at stake.
- Well, again, it's a
very simple idea, but
it is true that, I think, for 300 years
the focus in the analysis
of financial decisions,
decisions about money,
has been about wealth.
So people have talked about
the utility of wealth,
which is, what is the
psychological response to wealth?
And that people evaluate
different prospects
and opportunities by
evaluating them in terms of
what is called finite states of wealth.
Now, when I started studying this field
under the tutelage,
actually, of Amos Tversky,
who had studied it.
It was not my specialty.
I was struck by the absurdity of it.
And I was struck by the
fact that this is not
the way that people think about risk.
They think about risk in
terms of gains and losses.
You don't know what wealth you have.
Now it turns out that
that is a very fundamental
reorganization of the field.
A few think that outcomes are in terms of
gains and losses and
nothing to the final states,
so it opened up a whole agenda that people
are still working out.
- What I hear you saying, and I don't mean
to repeat myself, but
that by kind of narrowing
the focus, by having an intuition about
the way people are or the way you are,
as you said, that this is really central
to what's going on in your work.
- There are similar stages
to this, so this idea
of gains and losses, and
that people evaluate changes,
that I distinctly remember
how I had that idea,
so I was reading a chapter in a book that
Amos Tversky was one of
the authors of that book,
and it was a chapter on how
people analyze decisions.
Many important philosophers
had been analyzing
the so-called utility function
for money, and I noticed
that they never asked people about wealth.
They said, what about a
gamble in which you could
win that amount with a certain probability
or get that amount for sure.
They didn't do losses much,
but it was all about changes.
And I came back to Amos and I said, hey,
what's going on here?
They're asking questions about this
and then they're plotting a
function in terms of that.
That is psychologically very
implausible, so you need
to be able to pay attention to this.
And then you need to
realize that it's important.
So on the very day, it
was obvious that we would
never look at wealth
again, that we were going
to do something that is
psychologically realistic.
Of course he was immediately convinced.
Somebody else had had that idea before,
but they hadn't followed
through with it and we did,
so you need a very simple idea, and then
you need to see that it's important.
Then you need to follow through, and it's
a combination of tools.
- I'm curious because people
listening to your lecture
or listening to you now, the question is,
does your research offer
insights to individuals
with regard to how they might
change their own behavior?
- Well, yes, potentially it does,
but they're not insights
that are very easy to use.
You can be aware of mistakes
you make, and it's very
difficult to learn to avoid
them because System One
operates automatically.
Occasionally, when a
decision is very important
then you can stop to think,
and you have to recognize that
you can stop to think.
And then there is still the extra stage
which is a very painful
and difficult stage of,
even if your analysis
tells you to do something
when you don't want to do it, to impose
the discipline of
rationality on your desires
is extremely difficult.
I've just lived something like this
in deciding whether or
not to write a book, and
I just want to do it.
When I analyze the pros
and cons, it's absurd
for me to do this, but I'm
going to do it, I think.
So it's very difficult
to impose discipline
on yourself.
- In your lecture you
talked about individuals,
a fireman, a nurse,
who essentially develop
an intuition that is
critical to their career,
and their being able to see things.
Talk a little about that,
because you are approaching
the question of how a person develops
over time and kind of
masters their intuition.
- One of the important developments
in recent years in my life has been,
I try to understand controversy,
and I try to reduce controversy.
So we have, Tversky and
I, we made our reputation
by finding flaws in what people do.
It was the method we used.
It's not that we ever thought
that people are stupid,
but this is what we were doing.
Now, many people have
responded to that by saying
that we're drawing a distorted
picture of human nature,
and one of the people
who responded to that,
his name is Gary Klein, and he is the guru
of a movement that is called
natural decision making,
and they're very much
interested in intuition
and deliberately skeptical
about the kind of work
that we've done, and so I approached him
because I liked his work, actually.
And we've been
collaborating on an article,
so I was citing, in my lecture, examples
from his work in professional intuitions.
That as a fireman, a captain
of a firefighting company,
on the roof is suddenly
yelling to his company,
let's get out of here!
Just before the house explodes,
and then it turns out he wasn't aware
of where he was doing it,
but his feet were warm.
And that was the cue
that triggered the sense
that something very dangerous is going on
just underneath him.
That's a beautiful example
of the perfect intuition.
And that's the kind of
thing that has been feeding
people who think that all our discussions
of biases and mistakes
are overstated, so it sets
a very interesting problem that Gary Klein
and I have been trying
to sort out together.
When do intuitions develop
and when don't they?
Which experts can you
trust, and which experts
shouldn't you trust?
- In my notes for your lecture you said
that skills are acquired in an environment
of feedback and opportunity for learning
in a social network,
so that would help us understand
what makes it possible for
the fireman to be that way.
- They think about situations a lot,
and they think, they
talk about things a lot,
so they develop models of
various kinds of fires.
They don't have to experience.
We are really capable
of learning a great deal
from simulated experience.
Even athletes can learn
from simulating things
in their mind, and they do.
They practice a lot at night
without doing anything.
So this is one piece of
machinery that we dispose of.
It would not help you in certain domains.
It's not something that
a CIA analyst can do
because the system that they deal with
are fundamentally more complicated.
- Which raises the interesting question
of how groups can learn
from their own experience,
and so your work is
related to decision making
in the marketplace, and in
a minute we'll talk about
your article on foreign
policy, and in those cases,
what is the difference
when you have institutions
and groups that would like to correct
these kinds of errors?
- Well, in the first place,
my main observation would be that groups,
by and large, do not correct errors.
That's a recurrent observation.
There is a lot of lip
service paid in organizations
about improving the
quality of our intelligence
and the quality of our decision making.
But I think it's mainly lip service
because imposing a discipline
on decision making,
as I illustrated by my
example in the book,
I don't want to imposed
discipline on my decision making.
And so the leaders of organizations,
both civilian and
governmental and commercial,
they don't like to be
second-guessed, and so
by and large, it's the rare leader,
and there are very salient examples,
like the Bay of Pigs, I
mean after the Bay of Pigs.
Well, it's mainly actually
not the Bay of Pigs;
it's the Cuban missile
crisis is the example
that people think about,
as where somebody really,
the President Kennedy developed this team,
a deliberating team that
was superbly efficient
in allowing dissent and in allowing ideas
and in slowing down the
process of decision making
to a rate that was
appropriate to the complexity
of the situation.
That's very rare.
- And in some domains,
for example, politics,
the whole name of the game
becomes not to do what
the other party did and how they learned.
Now, recently you had an
article in Foreign Policy
which in a way, applying your
analysis to foreign policy
decision making is
pessimistic in the sense that
it suggests that hawks
have a structural advantage
in the sense that the choices
that they lean toward,
whatever the issue,
basically fall into many
of the categories that you've identified
in individual decision making.
- Yeah, I think that's right.
I think it's significant.
I think it's probably true.
I didn't expect to see
this but when I made
a list of the biases of human thinking
and decision making, it turned out that
in a situation of conflict, when conflict
is about to develop or
arise, then these biases
very consistently, I thought,
favor hawks over doves,
so that the claims of
hawks will resonate with
emotions and beliefs
and things that people
want to believe more
than the claims of doves,
and that was the point of that article.
- And in fact, there's an optimistic bias.
Well, we have all of this
military hardware; let's do
an illusion of control,
and we can go in there
and by defeating the adversary,
we can then take control.
- Clearly, it's very
clear whenever you look
at a serious conflict
or a war that there was
enormous optimism, usually on both sides.
It's not only on the losing
side that was optimistic.
The winning side didn't
appreciate the costs.
And that, I think, is regularly true.
It's very difficult to think of a conflict
in which anybody had
any idea, when it began,
how bad it was going to be for both sides.
Now, of course, it is the case that
when conflict breaks out
that there has been optimism,
but almost by definition, you
get optimists on both sides
of every conflict, and
when conflict arises,
pessimism becomes
disloyalty, so that doubting
our ability to achieve
victory, it would take
a very, very strong
national leader to be able
to sustain some doubter
in his inner circle,
when he himself wants to move forward.
- And unfortunately, in
terms of where we are now
it's difficult to cut losses.
I know that if one has a mutual
fund that has not done well,
one doesn't wanna move it
for fear that you will lose
even more by rationally moving it.
- Well, people in general don't
like cutting their losses.
And they're willing to
gamble on in the hope
of recovering their losses, and that is
a very well-known
characteristic of individual
decision making, and in
national decision making
it's exacerbated, because
the national leaders
who have led a country to close to defeat,
for them there is really
nothing further to be lost
by putting more at risk, and so there is
a real divergence of interest
between national leaders
and their communities when
the time to cut losses arrives
because cutting losses
is very rarely beneficial
to the decision maker.
- I would be interested
in your reflections
on human nature, actually,
because you've actually
devoted a whole career
to looking at the quirks
of our personalities, the blind spots
in our rational thinking.
Did you start with the same view?
Had you ended up in the same
place that you started with?
You started, you said, with complexity.
This choice, this
interaction with this soldier
in the streets of Paris,
you did was complexity.
Is that where you still
are and has anything
come out of your research
that has informed
whatever view of human nature you had?
- Again, they're very
different intellectual styles,
so there are some people
who summarize their world
and can summarize it in one big idea.
That's not the way my mind works.
So I think there is some coherence
in my view of the way
people work, but I have
built things one brick at
a time, and I don't think
I have a simple summary.
I can, in general, find
pretty good arguments
to reject any simple
idea about human nature,
but it's not that I have
a simple idea of my own
to substitute for it, so in that sense,
yes, complexity is my message.
- Now if students were
to watch this program,
do you have any advice for
them about how they should
prepare for their future if, for example,
they wanna go into the
field of psychology?
- My main advice would be to look at
the natural traps that await
anybody who does research.
And one of the real traps
is to get trapped by
a research program that is
fundamentally uninteresting.
And also, a reluctance to cut your losses,
so that when you've done
something that is not
very interesting, wasting
time trying to publish it
is almost always a big mistake,
so at least in my judgment.
So looking for things that are worth doing
and discarding things that
don't work, and knowing
that, if you're reasonably
good at what you're doing
and otherwise you shouldn't
be in that profession,
but if you're reasonably good at it,
then ideas are a dime a dozen.
You get lots of ideas.
You need some ideas that work
and that keep you excited,
and that you can do something with.
So not getting stuck on
an idea that doesn't work
but looking for other ideas.
That would be my general advice.
That has been how I've operated.
- Yeah, at the end of your
autobiography you go back
to your relationship with Amos Tversky,
and you quote him, and
I thought that these
were both very interesting comments.
You say, "But the other side of freedom
"is the ability to find
joy in what one does
"and the ability to adapt creatively
"to the inevitable."
And then you go on to tell
us that he often said,
"Let us take what the terrain gives."
- Well, this was a graveside eulogy
forward his scheming when he died in 1996.
So adapting to the
inevitable, I was commenting
on how he managed his death,
which was really exemplary.
He really did quite extraordinary things
in managing his dying.
Let's take what the terrain
gives was the expression
of his wisdom as a researcher
in his latter years.
And it's the idea that
you cannot really define
in advance the problem
that you're going to solve.
If you decide that I'm
going to solve this problem
you are not going to do it.
What you do is you are in that area
and you do the best you can.
You take what the terrain gives,
and you adapt to what it
is that you can find out,
and you don't try to force
your ideas on nature.
You're guided by what is achievable.
It's very good advice for some people,
but it was very good advice for him,
better than for me, for example, but yeah,
that was his intellectual style.
- In the final question,
you mentioned that
you might do another book.
Is there a piece of research, a set agenda
that you still wanna pursue in that space?
- I've been working for
the last 10, 12 years
on issues of well-being and experience,
and measuring experience, and the book
that I'm thinking about
is actually a trade book.
I don't know if it will happen at my age.
You never know, but it would really cover
the main topics that
I've worked on because
I've given a lot of public lectures,
and I like talking to lay audiences, and
in general I like thinking simply about
the things they do, and
so I thought it would be
a good opportunity to put things together.
So I think I'm going to try to do this.
- Do your insights about intuition apply,
are they a useful
foundation for understanding
what makes us happy?
Or is it a separate ...
- No, I think it's a separate ...
There is a lot in common
because there are certain
mistakes that we make
and anticipate what will
and will not make us
happy, and these mistakes
really are very well
understood by the notion
of substitution that I mentioned earlier.
We make highly predictable
errors in thinking
about our future, about
what makes us happy,
about what makes other people happy.
- On that note, Professor
Kahneman, I wanna thank you
very much for coming back to Berkeley
and for appearing on our program.
Thank you.
- Thank you.
- Thank you very much, and
thank you for joining us
for this Conversation with History.
(staccato synth music)